good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday after a
long weekend which is it's tough it's
tough It's not great I'm not gonna lie
but we're here so we're doing what we
got to do the good news is is that we
had an incredible weekend I know and
those memories should carry us through
yeah I believe it's what the kids call
Core memories right core memories this
weekend right what are core memories are
they what they I think they are or is it
an intrusive thoughts no no you
obviously and I know that you haven't
seen it yet and I don't know why that
you haven't seen inside out the Pixar
movie right so that's what it's from
like basically the movie takes place
inside the brain of a young girl okay
and all the difference I really do want
to see it all the different characters
are her different emotions like there's
Mindy Kaling is like the grumpy one and
they like facilitate her brain on a
day-to-day basis and memories come in
and they're different colors based on
what color the memory is if it's happy
you know and then every now and then a
golden one will come through to the
factory and it's a core memory and it's
usually like you know an iconic you know
dance side with her dad like a core
memory so a core memory is basically
like things moments that you will truly
remember forever they're usually family
oriented yeah um and so we had a bunch
of core memories this weekend this
weekend was a core memory no like that's
actually the perfect way to put it one
thing I really pride myself on is like I
could be on the most amazing vacation
like
glamorous luxurious but I've never like
one who's not ready to go home like once
it's time to go like I'm ready you know
me I'm a homebody I'm ready to go home
she's on the first flight out always
like even if it's the best trip ever I'm
never sad to go home because you're
never lingering no I've never
experienced as deep and as dark a
depression
that I have experienced in the last 24
hours like
it was a combination of like it being
such a great weekend rolled
and just like the weather like so many
other factors that like I actually cried
when I got home which is an unhinged
thing to do yeah I was crying in my bed
that's really sad I'm glad that you had
such a great weekend as did I it was
just we we needed it it was and also it
was such a great weekend for a million
reasons but I also think another reason
why it was we worked so hard last week
we were doing podcast podcast we even
podcasts our first day of vacation which
is a gorgeous stunning episode if you
didn't listen to it because you're like
oh they're off like it's not gonna be
the same it's incredible it's so good we
also did it outside on like the porch
which was such a good call because there
was no wind it wasn't like intrusive but
every now and then you heard a a chirp
of a bird the
to the sound of a leaf the mist of the
sunscreen yeah it was really an audio
experience it was an audio experience it
was ASMR if there was ever like the
potties you know like audio podcasts
outstanding outstanding performance in
audio engineering I think our episode of
Joseph Stalin like you've never seen her
before could qualify a hundred percent
plus it's funny as ever yeah we were
being great and so I'm just depressed it
was so nice to have a relaxing weekend
after that like no work we were all just
reading hanging it was
good family fun it was plus the sunshine
plus the rolled plus the rolled he makes
everything more special here's my
takeaway from the weekend waking up in
the same house is rolled
greater than not waking up in the same
house as world like there's something
about going to bed and giving rolled a
kiss and then waking up and giving World
a kiss
and I said to Claudia it sounds like you
want a baby no that's not it no I did
take another pregnancy test this morning
oh you took another one this morning my
period is eight days late that's crazy
which is nuts and I'm not like the most
regular girly but AJ's is a lot but I
have experienced a shift in diet and I
spoke to everyone about losing 15 pounds
I'm probably down to 13 now because of
the weekend but right
um yeah that'll do it you know like
that'll shift yeah change in diet will
change your period so I'm not like super
concerned but um I did take a pregnancy
test this morning and it was a negative
it was a little clock and then I was
like nope
sorry rolled sorry rolled no cousins for
you not today let's check with Kayla not
today not today rolled not today now for
those who don't know who wrote is I mean
we just though it's like a new iteration
of Harry's name and it's hat rolled for
Harold of course even though his name is
not Harold but he is named after our
grandpa Harold so right and his name
should be Harold we're honestly
um honoring our late grandfather by
using rolled 100 every time I said I
feel amazing I called him that back in
the day hundred percent so every time we
call them rolled I think of Roald Dahl
yeah which isn't great given the
anti-Semitism but
um writes of fire children's rights of
fire children make a book and some
things are just out of our control you
know you can't control everything no you
really can't everything's not going to
be perfect no but
it is what it is it is what it is I hope
everyone had as grateful weekend as we
did and it's you know easing back into
federal holidays are tough you know and
you know what not to get into the days
of the week again but that's what we do
here I think having the holiday on a
Monday sucks because nobody I don't feel
like anyone actually forced yesterday no
the fourth thing was happening over the
weekend yesterday everyone was just like
getting back to today like I think the
best day the holiday weekend the holiday
could be on Tuesday Tuesday or like
Wednesday and it's like [ __ ] it the
whole week is off well so Wednesday yeah
do you okay if the holidays on Wednesday
do you take the vacation Friday Saturday
Sunday Monday Tuesday Wednesday or
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday I don't know it's fun to play
around and think about it well I guess
we'll find out in two years unless
there's a leap year schedule so what's
next what's next holiday Labor Day
that's our next federal moment yes but
it's different like July 4th it's like
everybody takes long weekend actually
Labor day is always a Monday though yeah
no Labor day is good and then we have
Columbus Day which people have have
boycotted and I believe in and and
support the movement but I just don't
think we should be getting rid of
federal holiday off the calendar no I
think that's a huge mistake and I think
people are now rebranding it for
indigenous people day which totally
works but as long as we don't take our
eyes off the focus of not losing a
Federal holiday I agree people are
becoming like we're losing sight of
what's important the federal holiday
like I'm here for it I'm here for it
like I believe in the movement I support
the movement but like at what cost it's
becoming like Columbus Day Flex yeah and
this is not optional no I don't believe
in Flex uh federal holidays no and there
needs to be one federal holiday per
month for us to maintain our sanity and
have something to look forward is there
no we have MLK in January
presidents February March is that you
know like how they say in
um like Judaism it's like a bitter month
because there's no holidays but is there
there's Easter and Passover is that
usually April usually April okay there's
no yeah March is March the March is
usually spring break for the kids okay
okay well I'm not a child so but I think
you should take spring break April is
Passover and Easter so we get like you
know 75 of the country covered um not
all the religions that's not fair
um June we have may we have Memorial Day
amazing June we have Juneteenth yes July
4th August sometimes it's Labor Day
sometimes it's September yeah but August
is a vacation month in general that's
when people like go away do their thing
September we have a lot of Jewish
holidays so that's but they're sometimes
in October
we can't go by religious holidays no so
there's no federal in September unless
it's Labor Day and it usually is Labor
Day October Columbus
indigenous people yes November
Thanksgiving December Christmas okay
we're we're pretty okay there March we
could throw one in March and one in
August yeah but if you have spring break
in March that's a week yeah it's
gorgeous I used to take those for
granted you know oh hell yeah I did
sleep the whole time and it's like get
up and do something get your [ __ ] ass
up and vacate 100 vacate 100
um
so yeah we're all fighting our
slumps right now but that's what the
toast is here for to bring you out of
that slump and remind you that it's
Tuesday already which is a small win
it's a small win it's a small win and we
have to take these small wins it's a
shorter week and that's something we
have that we'll always have a short week
we'll always have a four day week yeah
we'll always have July 4th weekend yeah
it's just it was gorgeous what is it the
kids are doing um
like we do it together like this and
this no wait what do they do oh yeah
this sorry oh god with the middle finger
yeah no wait yeah yeah I got it
oh wait no I don't think you're doing it
right no I think I am it's just like a
sad
like cripply wouldn't want to be anybody
else it's not a good word no definitely
not that's what I meant like crinkled
yeah no but that was an ableist term
yeah I'm sorry I didn't I misspoke she
takes it back I do take it back we all
make mistakes every day every day look
at Columbus
[Laughter]
big mistake huge
um okay so that's really all I had to
share
I saw um a lot of celebrities over the
weekend The Hamptons was jam-packed with
celebs they were there are so many
stories about Hampton's parties I was
gonna say I saw a lot of movies this
weekend LOL we did uh we saw what was it
called The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
you guys Claudia and I had never seen it
before and everyone was like we should
watch it it was so Twisted very
upsetting it was crazy no and like we
watched it right before bed which was a
big mistake huge I was having nightmares
the entire night like in a deep sweat
very upsetting movie great performance
by everyone involved like movie was good
but at what cost my mental health yeah
no it was crazy and it was way too late
in the evening to be watching something
of that nature and we also watched girl
on a train with Emily Blunt which was
just like weird that we watched two
movies like girls
[Laughter]
um that movie was good like not great
but good I had read the book and they
were different so it was fine and I read
a bunch this week and I read the new
Emily Giffin um meant to be book which
is like Loosely based off the Kennedys
you would really like it I liked it too
I gave it four stars or maybe even five
it's just important to note that nothing
happened in the book but it was still
really good like someone was like what
is this book about I'm like it's about
people and they're living are they meant
to be
that's a good question huh I don't know
I finally finished my book The Lost
Summers of Newport maybe if I read it in
a timely fashion I would have liked it
but by the time I finished it it was
just like more
nonsense and I it was good it was fine
like whatever I I don't I don't know
like there was three different
characters three different time periods
and like some were far superior to
others you know that's like a lot of
books is like the the template of books
modern books is like story like they
split it up into like either parts or
perspectives from different people and
you always end up liking one of the
people better you know yeah the book I'm
reading now is like just just like girls
with Bright Futures exactly which is
perfect segue new episode of the
redheads dropped a few days early but
also a few days Lakes I said it was
going to drop over the weekend but it
dropped last night girls with Bright
Futures were recapping the book which we
spoiler alert all really really liked
and Claudia joins the episode because
she read the book with us so you know
she's not a Wallflower I would say so
she's really um
she's letting you know her opinions and
as someone who's not a Wallflower I can
say with absolute certainty there are
absolutely no Perks of Being a
Wallflower but you also wouldn't know no
I would you wouldn't no I would for sure
but the episode's really great so check
it out even if you didn't read the book
I think you'll like the episode because
it's super like toasty and steeny it was
really fun it was really fun um but I'm
reading a book now that's like
perspective of four different women and
they're in a book club what's a book
it sounds like my I know I cannot
remember the name you have a phone oh
yeah but um I took it from I've been
finding really good recommendations from
ke book club Kenzie Elizabeth she just
like posted we have the same like style
every now and then she'll throw in
something like serious or self-help that
I don't really she does a lot of like
non-fiction yeah but um she has good
recommendations for like speech reads
like if she likes a book you'll probably
like it if she didn't like it you
probably won't like it so I go into her
Instagram it's called the KE book club
and it's just like helpful book sorry
this is like my third book I've taken
from her the breakup book club it's cute
it's fun it's like that doesn't sound
like my vibe no
um and then also from help reads Margo's
friend Emily has a what do you call a
book and stuff a book Instagram a
bookstagram and I get a lot of good
recommendations from her I'm like
fighting book recommendations makes
reading not worth it it's literally so
hard I know it's so hard but now that
I've gone so long without reading as
much as I usually do I have so many good
books that I hope waiting for me also I
help reads looks like a very serious
bookstagram and I was like sometimes
like Ronnie you had a wreck for her from
her from the red eyes like she clearly
she reads I think the most books of
anyone that I know maybe Kenzie
Elizabeth they might be tied and she did
a few months ago and it was like
close work all roads lead here you might
like it except she was so verbose oh my
God she would not stop writing words
it's like she had a word count to me you
know I can't no I I can't it was like
lady books are the death of me my cross
to bear I won't read a book over 400
pages
you're missing some good books like you
wouldn't have read girls with Bright
Futures if I had told you it was over
400 Pages yeah and aren't you glad that
to have read it yes but if you're an
author and you can't get to the point of
400 Pages like maybe you're just not a
good writer and that's on being honest
okay but like what if there's more to
the story um Jackie that is like new
merch oh sure um it's our holiday
collection I'm so sorry but I'm cold
well if you're watching on YouTube you
got a sneak peek of our holiday blanket
okay I flipped it over okay
um uh so I had more to say because I
started a new book Tom Segura his book
called
no but like that I don't know how you
say but like sagura or like sagura yeah
no I can't say without pronunciating
every syllable I'd like to play alone
please he is a comedian and a podcaster
and I've only recently discovered his
work because of his wife's comedy
special Christina Christina P mom jeans
and then I was like Googling her so she
has a podcast and it's called your
mama's house and it's always on the
charts and she does it with her husband
Tom Segura who's also a comedian as well
so they're like this comedian podcasting
Duo love to see and he wrote a book of
short stories about like himself but you
know as a podcaster and a parent I feel
as though I could relate and I'm already
over 40 in and it's so [ __ ] funny I
was laughing like throughout the whole
weekend while I was reading it I was
sitting next to Jackie while she was
reading it and like every couple of
minutes she was like it's evil like
little
that that
so it's really funny and if you like
nonfiction slash a book of funny short
stories it's giving like Gary Genetti I
love a short story you would actually
really like it he's really funny short
stories maybe that'll be my next book
like I really respect the hustle of
short stories like thank you for getting
to the point immediately it's not too
far a short story I'm really literally a
short story yeah
so it was a great weekend we're back to
work we've got some past five we do and
by the by the time this is over it's
already Wednesday so so the week is
chugging along plus it's a summer
weekend you know it's gorgeous it
depends on what kind of weather you like
you know if you're more it's one of
those people who actually appreciates
the winter like us you know yeah very
hard but that was another key factor of
the weekend while the weather was
gorgeous and we were able to swim even
though I did get swimmers here also like
I'm incapable of going on vacation and
not coming back with some sort of
ailment what are the doctor after this
because of your rash did you see my rash
I did last time I went to Mexico I got a
rash and I got like strep this time I
got swimmers here and another rash like
maybe I'm too adventurous for my own
good you just are so outdoorsy yeah it's
just it's too much so it's not just me
like I always come back with some sort
of issue
it's not like I went anywhere mysterious
I went to The Hamptons there's a lot of
mosquitoes out there ticks too I am
worried I might have limes like from
this bite even though I was Googling
pictures of like a tick bite versus my
rash and they couldn't be more different
but of course a major concern of being
in Long Island is Lyme's disease yeah
and it wasn't even in the woods but I
did go in there a couple times chasing
Theo so we'll see oh and you guys the
stress bro there's uh and their lady
love Magnolia had the weekend of their
lives it was just it was one of those
vacations that keeps you going
zest for life that's us that's us
so let's Jump Right In but before we do
I just wanted to take a moment to send
our prayers and our thoughts to the
people of Highland Park Illinois there
was a shooting there were shootings all
over the country in the world this
weekend and it's just so upsetting to
see like there's evil in my foot
um and I was looking through stories
this morning and there's just so much so
much bad news and it's so hard to like
pick mindless celebs and focus on it
when there's really sad things going on
but we just wanted to take a moment
um send love to our Chicago toasters yes
hope everyone's okay
so now without further Ado it is time
for the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
Missouri most people think about buying
jewelry for occasions only but majority
does Fine Jewelry differently by
celebrating every day and not just the
big moments their high quality pieces
are designed for you to wear your way
whatever your taste is whatever your
mood is and whatever your budget is
Missouri drops new limited edition
products every Monday and they feature
responsibly sourced diamonds recycled 14
karat solid gold pieces that you can
wear in When you sweat you can wear it
in the shower you can sleep in it you
can discover fairly priced and expertly
handcrafted styles to wear and love
forever so this summer is the summer of
like dainty gold jewelry whether that's
bracelets necklaces stacked rings and
either you're gonna pay a lot for that
which is annoying or you're going to pay
very little and get like green fingers
and tarnished items that turn different
colors and they turn your skin different
colors that's why Missouri is our pick
for dainty gold moments
because this might be the sign that you
need invest a little bit in your dainty
gold self Missouri is there for you they
have all different types of pieces for
different styles whatever your Vibe is
whether it's like more boho or more
classic you can find really everything
you need at Missouri if you're looking
to um for a sign to buy yourself the
diamond or gold hoops bracelets and
necklaces then this is it make your own
day and go to missouri.com that's
m-e-j-u-r-i.com
missouri.com check it out I discovered
Missouri from Lauren Elizabeth because
she's like the gold dainty Queen
um and ever since then like whenever I'm
really looking for something like nice
that I know is not going to get ruined
but that's you know reasonably priced
Missouri is a One-Stop shop and the tick
tockers love Missouri so gen Z is very
like it's Missouri approved yeah so for
me you know an aspiring tick tocker it's
huge great today's episode is also
brought to you by hungry root if you're
trying to eat a little healthier feel a
little better or have an easier time in
the kitchen we have found the easiest
way to do it all and the secret is
hungry root because sometimes there's
nothing easier than just ordering
takeout for dinner it feels easy but it
really adds up and then on the other
hand just thinking about grocery
shopping and having to play the what's
for dinner game is exhausting so if you
hate grocery shopping or you simply
don't have the time hungry root is here
to help the easiest way to get fresh
high quality food delivered to your door
they've got healthy groceries simple
recipes all in one place you'll take a
fun short quiz and hungry we will get to
know you your goals and how you like to
eat if you're gluten-free do you like
sweets they'll keep all of that top of
mind for you and start building your
cart hungry root will recommend
groceries that they think you'll love
you'll take their suggestions or choose
what you want from fresh produce high
quality Meat and seafood Pantry Staples
healthy snacks and sweets and so much
more you're not just getting your weekly
grocery haul but you can also shop
thousands of simple recipes that
actually put your food to use that I
think is one of the best parts of
Hungary like you can go to the grocery
store you want to make some dish and
then you get home and realize you forgot
half the stuff no they'll you could
choose a recipe and they will literally
tell you exactly what you need for the
recipe so that it all arrives at your
house like it's so simple and it's so
easy you'll spend less time shopping and
cooking and more time enjoying healthy
food that you actually love with hungry
root and right now hungry root is
offering the morning toast listeners 30
off your first delivery and free veggies
for life life just go to hungryroot.com
toast to get 30 off your first delivery
and get your free veggies that's
hungryroot.com toast don't forget to use
our link so they know that we sent you
and whether you're gearing up for just
like a a busy week with kids and family
you're having company come over it's
really premium and it'll just make your
food life way more efficient and we're
all about efficiency here at the morning
toast yeah we are our first story ships
are coming in are you ready for the
latest couple spotted out together that
is sparking Joy Chris Rock and Lake Bell
fuel romance rumors with dinner date in
La this is so random but like so cute
and also like why did I just think Chris
Rock was like married yeah I just
assumed yeah like because he's just like
an older gentleman I just assumed to be
like had like a wife and kids at home
yeah he might have at one point yeah no
for sure but now he's adding fuel to
romance rumors with Lake Bell and
exclusive picks obtained by Page Six
the pair were spotted leaving a dinner
date at celebrity hotspot Giorgio Baldi
in Santa Monica on Saturday night
so I mean do people last time we saw two
people going to dinner our children Joe
Baldi was Angelina Jolie in the weekend
and I still think they're in business
together but I do think this is a
relationship I do too which means that
they're in business together I think
they're they're both like really famous
private people so like
this just feels like
like it's a lot for me to know about
Chris Rock do you know what I mean oh
true I thought you were going to say
because they were both very famous
private people this feels right you know
by the way for sure but does anyone else
get Lake Bell confused with Liv Tyler no
I get her confused with Catherine Hahn
how because they're always like the
supporting funny friend well I always
think of um
but she's complicated she does look like
Liv Tyler yeah she does for me they
always play the same roles you know
that's so funny no because like Lake
Bell I'm thinking of like what happens
in Vegas and she's like that's a
Catherine Hahn role oh that's funny
that's Catherine Hahn in How to Lose a
Guy in 10 Days uh okay so I think of
Lake Bell I think of how to Make It in
America and um It's Complicated where
she plays Alec Baldwin's like mistress
turned wife turned ex-wife oh spoiler
alert
um and oh actually now that I think
about it she's in a lot of Nancy Myers
movies she's home again home again where
she plays that difficult interior design
client for Reese Witherspoon
um so yeah she's like famous but like
not a star she's never like a leading
lady yeah
hmm that ain't right it ain't right
because she's got the chops um but maybe
this relationship we love a relationship
that you know people are in love but it
also catapults their career right
and pleasure yeah so maybe this is the
thing maybe her next Nancy Myers movie
is the lead
and as a society we could use another
Nancy Myers movie stack well I feel like
we spoke about this a little while ago
but when the last one was the intern
right yeah well I don't think we spoke
about it because we were looking for
Nancy Myers movies no sorry the last one
was home again oh wait which one came
out first
we could look but it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter okay just home again is
from 2017. so that maybe they were okay
hold on let's show them now we just need
to scratch the itch yeah the intern
movie is from 2015. what I was going to
say 2015. so the last movie was home you
had like three minutes the last week was
home again and honestly I don't think
the reviews for Nancy were that Rave but
did you see Nancy in architectural
digest yes I did I never clicked
something so fast in my [ __ ] life I
know me too because I don't really have
like um an interior Decor like
go-to style if someone was like if
someone came to like dream we're gonna
make you your dream house what's your
style like I don't [ __ ] know
yes Rachel parcel but that's not like
you know an official art deco or like
modern contemporary for me it is yeah so
um
when I saw Nancy Myers I was like oh man
that's my style it's very Coastal
grandmother actually she is the coastal
grandmother and that is your style and I
feel like you've realized that recently
yes
um grandmother is an aesthetic yes
but so I literally ran to architectural
address I've never been on that website
before my entire life actually did it on
my computer like I don't even think my
phone could do it justice
um and you know what I noticed about
Nancy Myers she loves a ranch she
doesn't like homes with stairs
relatable Queen relatable Queen it was
beautiful yeah really I highly recommend
going to check it out now back to like
Belle yeah and back to rage I do think
architectural digest should do racha's
house I completely agree I adjust I
completely agree yeah like an
architectural digest really wants to be
like on the trigger of what's going on
in society and culture and design they
would know that rage parcel's home is
like where it is at and needs to be
photographed even though like
she photographed it for her own website
and it was just as good I know but it's
just like you want that AED stamp of
approval and maybe like because you know
they like to do like new homes like they
could do Emily Jackson's news right her
sister's about to like build this big
house it looks so gorgeous and Drew is
building it and it's a parcel Family
Affair you know what it is it's a parcel
family core memory
we are actual losers and we are not okay
no we're not okay but this is cute what
is the age difference between Lake Bell
and Chris so glad you asked I had the
same question he's 57 okay surprising
she's 43. I love age-appropriate moments
they're both fully formed adult humans
this is great I mean we're never gonna
be like we're never gonna get what we
really if even if they are like
long-term and in love forever we're
never gonna like really get to know them
they're both so private and we're not
gonna really know what they're like as a
couple yes but like going to Giorgio
Baldi it's not the most subtle movie
it's a thirsty move yeah it's not like
the thirstiest you know it's not the ivy
but it's not private like no it's not a
PDR yeah at a restaurant that we've
never heard of yeah this is really cute
and I'm really happy for them and I just
feel like this might be the year of
Chris Rock like I feel like everyone's
on his side he's got a new lady his
ticket sales went through the roof after
the Will Smith thing tickets tickets
he's kind of like America's sweetheart
right now I love this and I guess I
would make
Lake Bell like the first lady of America
yeah
you'd love to see you you love to see it
not to put too much pressure on them or
anything no they're having a good time
there's only one couple we preserve our
insane pressure for and that's Craig and
Paige
yeah no there's a couple couples I was
gonna say crage and Peg yeah no I was
thinking about their couple name a few
days ago I don't know why like it's not
good greater Peg yeah it's not gonna
work no it's not gonna work there's a
couple couples that like
actually you think that and then these
ships sink all the time and I'm able to
move on yeah this was like a our most
recent one was Lori Harvey and Michael B
Jordan like that was a tough blow but
look we're still standing I'm still
standing better than I ever did I could
never write that song I'm like a new
survivor I'm still sitting better than I
had before
speaking of someone who's got the music
in him who red blood
miles teller's Grandma campaigns for him
to be the next James Bond by the way I
saw the story and I had never considered
Miles Teller for this role and now it's
really like it's the role he was born to
play yeah Miles Teller is great
it's the role he was born
I'll tell her it's Grandma I believe the
actor would be perfect as the next James
Bond now that Daniel Craig has retired
from the role has he yeah this has been
like a big question and by the way I
think at the end of the day Daniel
Craig's going to wind up doing another
movie it's been a big question for 15
years yeah and we're always theorizing
who it could be and there's been a lot
of great names put forward but I think
this is the one yeah well because okay
so wait can I tell you what she tweeted
on Wednesday oh she's a Twitter she
tweeted they're looking for an actor to
replace Daniel Craig for future 007
movies I think my grandson Miles Teller
has proven that he has everything
they're looking for talent looks
strength worldwide appeal and oh so cool
she can be that guy wouldn't he be great
yes this first of all yes Leona flowers
this is so Earnest like the way she
wrote I die yeah second of all by the
way I completely agree and I had never
really thought about it because we've
been having this conversation for so
many years and Daniel Craig is like kind
of being like click bait [ __ ] starter
like pick me energy no I'm not gonna do
another one okay
annoying and so for a while like 10
years ago when he was actually like for
the first time said he might not return
Idris elba's name was floated as like
the guaranteed next but now it's like
Idris Elba is the same age as Daniel
Craig they're both getting old like it
doesn't solve the problem so for so long
I was like when he's done it's going to
be Idris Idris but now it's like too
much time has passed and taking on
someone
not to be Aegis but like older doesn't
solve the problem right we only still
get like a few movies and then we're
back so I do think they should go
younger but not too young because like
007 has to have some experience right so
we need to reset yes
so Miles Teller is an amazing Choice
um I think if Bond wanted to capitalize
on the momentum of like Top Gun they
should like do that soon but also maybe
it's too similar but you know who I kind
of see now that I'm thinking about it
Glenn Powell okay he would be great but
Taryn Edgerton even though like the
kingsman might be too similar yeah but
he was given bond energy and he was also
some fans responded to Grandma's tweet
saying that he's not British and you
know bond is Brit taranus and she wrote
he could make you think he was from
Great Britain and lots of Europeans have
played Americans he studied acting which
includes accents he'd be great it's
she's so logical she has an answer for
everything rational Queen like no you're
right he's literally an actor that's why
he would act British she's like are you
new here
are you dumb yeah like it's called
acting look it up
um but this is always just a fun
conversation to like think of who I
guess really it should be someone
British that's a fair point that person
made
um and I think Tara and Edgerton could
do it I think that's a pretty good call
but it does feel like he would be really
pigeonholing himself into like one genre
but he was also Elton
Elton yeah maybe Bond could do a musical
number he's very musical Taran and he's
also into the sing movies is he yeah I
believe so because the version of I'm
still standing that I'd like to listen
to is from Taran you're right
so um miles is always a great choice
like you're never going to be like oh I
wish I didn't cast Miles Teller because
he's always going to deliver but you
know who it's going to be who gets the
British actor who gets put in everything
Dominic West
John by the way Jackie totally you're
100 no you're you're literally 100 right
that's who it's gonna be at the end of
the day even though this is going to be
like every roll but I do want to say and
we said it the Dominic West was very
lovely in downtown too yes my only thing
and this might be like a little harsh
but people have been saying this about
women so I don't feel bad he's not
really like good looking enough because
like he's obviously a movie star he's
handsome but he's not like that um like
Hollywood face you know what I mean
Miles Teller is a Hollywood face that
was mean I'm sorry but like he's just
not it's okay I don't think he's gonna
hear it no but Jackie I cannot believe
actually I might I can't believe you
like 100 just predicted who bond is
gonna be like it's literally 100 gonna
be dominant dominant class and we're all
gonna like be like begrudgingly going to
see it and then we'll be like oh he was
gonna good yeah I've never seen a Bond
movie in my life what but I can't but I
want to sorry I guess that's not that
crazy I've only seen like one I'm
interested
yeah I saw 007 no but anytime like we
were looking for movies this weekend and
I would suggested Skyfall because I
haven't seen it but everyone else has
seen it so I have to literally watch
them all by myself no honestly like I
really don't think you need to see them
and I think I get the point yeah we were
like on we were trying to get like our
Miles Teller fixed this weekend every
time we like went to go
look for a movie we would just like type
in Miles Teller yeah but you know what
also with all the new movies coming out
and I know like we're glad the movie
industry is like getting back on its
feet but like there's really no reason
July 4th weekend why like Elvis and Top
Gun shouldn't have been available for
purchase on Amazon Prime or something or
iTunes
like it's annoying it's really annoying
and they put it up for pre-order and
it's like so you see it you're like oh
my God I could watch Elvis pre-order
who's pre-ordering a movie it's also
like it's such an archaic model that it
has to go to the theaters and then you
can get it at home like we're living in
2022 like we could do both no and if
it's like for monetary reasons make it
what cost what is it like 15 20 a ticket
for movies
all right so let's say three of us are
watching when I pay 60 for a movie well
I don't know you could charge more kind
of how they did Mulan yeah I think it
was like 50 bucks yeah yeah I'll do it I
really wanted to watch Elvis Top Gun
I've seen it all right
but anyways I'm with Grandma I'm with
Grandma too hashtag miles for Bond miles
for Bond love that are you ready for our
next story it's just like now kind of
hitting me that miles's name is Miles
you know what I mean because no one ever
calls it miles he's Miles Teller yeah so
I guess I just never really he's a first
elastic he's a first elasti so I never
really sat down and thought about the
fact that his name is Miles and now that
you're thinking about it what do you
think it just makes me think differently
of the name because like whenever people
around me are like having babies and
they're like going through names so
smile sometimes comes up and I'm like
that was me yeah I don't know if you
were like gonna use it so like I didn't
want it I don't think so so like when
you set it up I always think back to
like the one miles that like I knew
growing up and I hated the name you know
yeah but it never really occurred to me
that like that name is also miles
teller's name do you know what I mean
yeah you know what I think about what I
think about the lyric even though we're
miles apart no and then also Oh I wanna
do Jackie and then also when Zac Efron
is late so she goes even if we're miles
and miles and miles and miles apart
that's literally I think of that every
single time that's interesting
so that's just a little bit about you
yeah uh but it's a gorgeous name and a
gorgeous man you should play James Bond
100 like
you know that Tick Tock sound I love
this man no I don't I think it's Demi
Lovato speaking that's funny and that's
literally how I feel about Miles Teller
I'm just like let's not forget like we
literally met him oh yeah at the Super
Bowl and he he recognized us yeah yeah
iconic are you ready for our next story
no why not because the next story is
brought to you by Olive and June Manny
system it's everything you need for
Salon quality manicure in one box so you
order the Olive and June Manny set you
can customize the system with your
choice of six polishes their polishes
are premium they do not chip they last
seven days or more and then when you
break it down you stop paying for
manicures you buy the manicure system
you're breaking it down to just two
dollars a manicure
there's nothing like a mood booster like
having fresh nails but it can get so
expensive and then you do it at home you
don't have the right products and it's
just like that makes you really feel
terrible about yourself so it's super
easy to get Salon worthy nails at home
with Olive and June there's a huge
difference between how your nails used
to look when you did them yourself and
now with the Mani system
um it's super affordable they have
everything you need they have the bot
the buff they have the cuticle oil of
course they're gray polishes they also
have this silicone topper that you put
on top of their nail polishes that
really helps you steady your hand when
you're doing your right hand because
obviously we can all do our left hands
great then the right hand comes and it's
just like looks like you bled all over
yourself but their silicone topper stops
that shakiness in your hand and it's
really just it's premium and it really
works
you can visit Olive and june.com TMT for
20 off your first Mani system the real
the reason why I really like it is
because like whenever
I like I'm having a nail issue at home I
never have like the right stuff you know
but that little kid it comes with
everything a file a buff cuticle oil
like the cuticle the cuticle oil I'm
always like rubbing on my fingers right
before bed it's just nice to have all
that stuff in your house and you just
buy the Mani system their polishes are
so nice so if you're going to a wedding
you just need like a last minute just
throw it in your suitcase it's really
premium and again Olive and june.com TMT
will get you 20 off your first Mani
system
o-l-i-v-e-a-n-d-j-u-n-e.com slash TMT
for 20 off your first Mani system great
thank You Adele is standing by her
decision to cancel her Las Vegas
residency she says it wasn't good enough
so Adele was on BBC Radio 4's desert
island discs and she's talking about the
Vegas gate she said quote I definitely
felt everyone's disappointment and I was
devastated and I was frightened about
letting them down and I thought I could
pull it together and make it work and I
couldn't and I stand by that decision
she added that the backlash was brutal
and left her as a shell of a person for
a couple months despite receiving
venomous venomous response from
disappointed fans and possibly wasting
tons of cash on the show's production
the singer refused to budge she said
quote you can't buy me you can't buy me
for nothing I'm not going to just do a
show because I have to or because people
are going to be let down or because
we're going to lose loads of money um
like the show's not good enough while it
was billed as a postponement she has yet
to create concrete plans for makeup
shows she said quote I'm not going to
update you if I got if I ain't got
nothing to update you with because that
just leads to more disappointment it's
like I I respect her you know quest for
Perfection but this is like a little
rude like just like literally
acknowledging the disappointment from
her fans people like spending so much
money on tickets on flights some people
were already there by the time because
she announced it like really close to
the performance so
just giving like a little rude like yeah
it's a little rude I think the only you
know
thing that she should really be
concerned with because there was a lot
of different like factors that go into a
cancellation I think a lot of people are
disappointed but I think like really
like those fans who paid so much who you
know flew across the country who got the
sitter like
that's who it's really
sad for yeah and like while I do respect
like taking a stance and like digging
your heels in it's just giving like a
little
a little ungrateful you know like and
just not even acknowledging like the
fact that like I saw so many tick tocks
of people who literally found out the
show was being canceled like while on
the plane yeah so it's just like so many
people spending like so much money to
see like their icon and of course things
don't work out and if the show wasn't
ready like she says but like it's just
so hard to believe to
to think about how unready it could be
like the show is her right she doesn't
do backup dancers there's not crazy
lights I mean so she the reason why she
was on BBC Radio is because her Hyde
Park show was this weekend I saw it all
over Tick Tock people have been talking
about it for months and of course it was
incredible she was literally just
standing there singing right so really I
can't imagine what else that's why it's
like hard to believe believe I would
have I would have an easy time
understanding like and she would never
do this but like Taylor Swift like the
pyrotechnics the dancers the singers the
sets like it's and she always says like
her shows are a full
production because she always says like
you never know what's coming to the show
sometimes obviously it's super fans
people's parents people got dragged
there and she was like there's something
for everyone you can appreciate the
dancing the singing the the sets the
pyrotechnics so or like Katy Perry doing
the most have you seen Katy Perry's
Vegas show there's a big ass toilet and
a big [ __ ] comes out of it and there's a
man like with toilet paper like it's
she's lying no you haven't seen that
everyone's like it's so Camp I'm like is
Camp gross yeah that are okay I'm taking
a [ __ ] in the woods yeah she like
literally
um like slides out of the toilet like if
he's disgusting yeah for sure that's
disgusting know what I'm saying they
could get this big ass toilet in Vegas
but we do need to focus on the toilet so
especially seeing her her Hyde Park
performance
which was understated beautiful it was
outside like she didn't need anything
it is difficult to understand how like
Vegas couldn't get you know the lights
on yeah that that part is weird and also
like at the end of the day I feel like
I'm using that phrase a lot and I'm like
on love Island but that because people
on this week a hot new bombshell enters
the Villa I'm picking this boy because
I have no one else to choose and at the
end of the day and at the end at the end
of the day like this isn't a huge deal
in the grand scheme of things you know
it's a concert that didn't work out and
the scope of the big bang when you zoom
out
she did the show you know
the whole thing is so smelly yes that
it's like really become like a stain on
her reputation and like it's it seems to
be indicative of a larger issue yeah and
everyone kind of feels that way yeah no
you're definitely right that it's a
stain because it's so
rare that's a bizarre it's bizarre this
just like doesn't it show business The
Show Must Go On the way it went down is
bizarre too because you know what like
how do you only realize like the day
before that the show's not ready right
and a show that again is like a
one-woman show yeah but you know there's
Orchestra of course wardrobe and whatnot
but like she's the type of artist where
it's like you know Katie Herron When the
Music Stops like she can just keep
singing right no and it makes me really
think of Katy Perry's documentary part
of me like if Katy Perry can do a show
in Rio after her husband literally
called her five minutes before and told
him he wanted a divorce then Adele could
get her [ __ ] ass up and sing in Vegas
that's so funny that you remember that
documentary like backwards and forwards
because I saw it and oh it's one of my
like favorite I always mention it in my
celebrity document like I saw it in
theaters and then I never saw it again
and honestly I forgot what I saw it was
extremely raw and her grandma like you
don't she literally was like doing the
biggest show of her life in Rio and
she's in her dressing room her husband
literally calls her and I was like I
want a divorce babe and she's like what
and then she has to she's literally
hysterically crying doing her hair
makeup and goes on stage and delivers
the performance of a lifetime that was
like P Katy para Katy Perry era yeah
Katy Perry
yeah so if she can do that like we all
we can do anything you can get your
[ __ ] ass up and work so the thing
like so to suffice to say that at the
end of the day it feels like it's
connected to something right and that
she probably could have done one show
and and then like you know what the show
wasn't what I wanted to be I'm Gonna
Cancel the rest and I'll come back and
try again yeah and at the end of the day
it's important to remember like
an Adele show is Adele
it's not this like big spectacle yeah
and like that's what I was thinking when
I was watching her Hyde Park tick tocks
like she literally looks gorgeous just
in a simple black dress no big dancers
or lights or screens behind her just
Adele and people like wear a gagged
crying screaming throwing up yeah
so I don't understand so it seems like
there's more to the story hence the
smelliness yeah and I really think it
would behoove her to stop talking about
it because every time we like talk about
it again I'm reminded of how bizarre it
is yeah so she really needs to sell and
then even though like it's not a big
deal in the grand scheme of things it
just like is indicative it makes you
think of the bigger situations nefarious
effect yeah
are you ready for our next story which
is a follow-up to a story from Thursday
which really shouldn't be a big deal yet
nevertheless we persist
Olivia O'Brien says that she never dated
Pete Davidson have you heard I heard
that Pete Davidson is like Pete
Davidson's rep told page six on
Wednesday after Olivia O'Brien was on
the BFF BFF's podcast saying that he
broke up with her over text then Pete's
rep said there's no truth to this they
were friends and hung out a few times
now Olivia O'Brien posted on her
Instagram story saying news outlets are
taking things I said in an interview
after being asked a very specific
question way out of context I never
claimed to date anyone stop trying to
start weird drama over me texting
someone two years ago Jesus Christ and
then she said watch the interview or
shut your mouth at all the news outlets
posting fake stories about me well
that's fair because I was talking about
it and I didn't even see the interview
so right I saw like a tiny Club but we
did have the quote which was
um
first they brought up the dumois item
then she said she didn't think anyone
knew about that
and that it happened a long time ago I
guess like none of those things said I
dated Pete Davidson yeah
so these two didn't date but they texted
and he then he was dating Phoebe in a
more serious way honestly it's exactly
what I said happened right like he
wasn't doing anything nefarious but I do
it must be annoying for Olivia like
because now it's making it seem like
she's a thirst monster she went on this
podcast talking about Pete Davidson
who's dating Kim Kardashian and then
Pete had to be like [ __ ] I literally
don't know who this person is and I
never dated her and it makes her look
bad but no but it makes her look bad but
I don't I don't think I love her after
this I can see how the miscommunication
happened and I actually was the one who
sorted through it last week yeah I could
say this miscommunication happened as
well
um
but this is unfortunate for Olivia for
sure yeah because it it just it makes
her
like look weird
like and like thirsty you know what I
mean yes but and she's like fighting
back being like no I'm literally not
yeah but people don't care like they
just read the headlines yeah yeah but I
personally know she didn't mean it that
way no and I'm I'm
this doesn't change how I feel about
Olivia O'Brien if anything like I just
feel like a little sympathy for her now
because like this sucks yeah it's like
it's embarrassing but she's in the press
and now it's two days in a row of
talking about her on the toes like you
know there's pros and cons to everything
there's no such thing as bad press no
And as far as bad press goes this really
isn't a big deal but it's just like a
little funny and and weird no it's
embarrassing for everyone involved I
hope that it was worth a [ __ ] Jocelyn
yeah and I'm glad that you shared with
me um the the story of Olivia O'Brien
the story of Olivia O'Brien because now
I I I stand completely yeah yeah but
just making sure that was the right word
yeah are you ready for our fifth and
final Story Only visit the final story
that's brought to you by honey do you
think that that that's yeah and I think
that really every story can be brought
to you by honey that's how pertinent to
your situation honey is now listen up
listen up honey is giving very canva Pro
like I really don't feel like I need to
explain to you why you need honey
because like what I took me me forcing
you to better your life like just do it
save money so here's how it works
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite websites when you check out the
honey button will simply drop down all
you have to do is Click apply coupons
and within a few seconds honey is
searching for coupons it can find on
that website and if it finds a working
coupon you will watch the price drop
I've used honey for years and years and
years makeup clothing Tech food
literally every website it's free when
you use our link download the browser
extension and then you're shopping you
even forget you have it before you press
check out this little man pops up he's
like the little honey gold coin he's
like hey girlie want to save some money
press click of high coupons take a sip
of your water by the time you come back
they found a coupon that works I used to
manually research like uh promo code for
and it's like takes forever and it's
none of them ever work honey will do all
the work for you and it's in an instant
you're saving so much money honey has
saved people so much money
you can add honey to your iPhone too now
do you know that no yeah you just enable
it on Safari and you find savings on the
go oh my God I don't have to be a
grandma like only shopping on my
computer right so if you don't already
have honey you are straight up missing
out it is free to install and it
downloads in seconds you'll be doing
yourself a solid and we would never
recommend something we don't use we have
been honey girlies long before they were
sponsor on the show so you can get honey
for free when you go to joinhoney.com
toast that's joinhoney.com toast I don't
really
um feel the need to explain myself
further like if you're if you're not
going to take control of yourself and
better your life like there's not much I
can do for you no literally I shop so
much online yeah excessively almost and
honey is there with me everywhere I go
honey is that [ __ ] has always been that
[ __ ] will always be that [ __ ] yes now
our fifth and final story is a bit of a
throwback some Bachelor Alum news okay
someone we haven't spoken about in so
long is engaged okay Chase McNary oh is
engaged to Ellie white those thighs
remember the thighs yep on Instagram on
Saturday day he announced his engagement
to his girlfriend he shared the news
alongside moments from the romantic
proposal occurring in Breckenridge
Colorado including a shot of himself
getting down on one knee that is so
sweet I didn't see that for him because
like he entered a major fuckboy era
afterwards like with Robbie Hayes like
being losers
um and then I kind of like stopped
keeping up with him because even though
his thighs were gorgeous it just wasn't
enough to keep me interested yeah
um and it's nice to know like he is you
know settled down right oh my God I'm
thrilled for him yeah I'm really happy
for him too and you know what like I
mean it just is such a throwback to like
those days when we were so immersed in
Bachelor of life and I think that like
when you get so famous from a show
you're gonna inevitably of course
do your thing human nature it's human
nature but now he's and some people
never flaw out of that like yeah so I'm
happy he got to like have fun I'm sure
he was like you know hooking up with a
lot of girls in his DMS and all that so
he had his fun and now he's gonna settle
down and I love that he was like one of
my favorites on jojo season yeah he was
one of my favorites like ever like of
men from the franchise and I remember
like literally like I'll never like not
laugh at the memory of him getting sent
home he was being so funny remember that
yeah he was like cursing and drinking in
a band yeah um and then he went on
Paradise and he was he's just like
really handsome and I was very taken by
him and I thought for sure he was going
like all the way but he made it to top
four or something
um
and so that's nice that's nice really
really nice oh I'm so happy for him what
is his girlfriend like do you know
anything about her uh yes I believe that
well based on this article I didn't
really know he was in such a serious
relationships
oh nice interior
fashion Coastal grandmother well if you
look at her look from the engagement
it's getting she's very stylish yeah she
looks like Meghan Markle from the back
oh totally
very cute very cute I think this is
lovely I'm so what a random Fifth and
final random Fifth and final also like
speaking of those back in the days of
Bachelor we never even talked about it
Joe and Jordan got married got married
finally they're nice and also have you
seen Blake and gianina like all over
social media
I have
and you know they just need to clarify
because we were talking about that show
like all XR Island and I thought that
they went on together because we knew
that they were dating but they met their
show they filmed it a while ago because
now I've been together for like I know
one of them posted like a carousel yeah
and it's like oh my God they've done so
much stuff together they're like really
in a relationship yeah they do say if
you have nothing nice to say like don't
say it and I'm up for people being happy
so I hate to be like you know I'm just
not going to like okay you guys know
what I think like you know you literally
if you know me like you know
yeah I want my butterflies back
that was like the first season of Love
is Blind was literally like a cultural
shift yeah
and now that I think about it like who
from that show is still like gianina's
obviously like still making a name for
herself yeah obviously the Hamiltons
will always be I think a lot of people
have like settled in their roles as
influencers right like the Hamiltons
have like a pop-in YouTube channel
called The Hamiltons and then of course
Amber and Barnett who are very much like
you know influencers are they I don't I
don't think I follow anyone from Mark um
has a I think like a second or third
baby on the web yes yes I did see that
yeah I haven't heard from Jessica but I
do believe she's probably scarred from
the I mean she's like engaged or good
like that was not a good time for her no
who else was on the show oh Damien
then they all like kind of came back in
this love is mine too it was weird yeah
um wow okay well those were the first
five stories I feel as though you needed
to know them it does feel like a
lifetime ago when we like gave a [ __ ]
about the bachelor I know and now I
think was like the last good season of
The Bachelor
well it's hard because I do think like
Hannah Brown's season was probably good
but we didn't watch it right
um then there was Peter season which was
the biggest waste of my time on the
planet like I the reason why I have a
garage towards Peter Weber is because of
all the time he stole from me yeah
and then after Peter it was Claire cross
that's when I think things got bad like
the choice to have it be clear when
there was like all these girls from here
season who people really enjoyed right
and Hannah Ann's doing really well too I
think she has a man who plays yeah and
she like like makes a lot of Premium
content content she's like does recipes
and videos yeah she seems to be at a
good place in her life she seems to be a
very good Chef then it's also so crazy
to think about like the OG Girls and the
career like the Becca Tilly Amanda Stan
who have like full-fledged like
pop in careers it's just so interesting
but then it's also interesting like to
see the girls who tried it and failed
you know but I don't there's not really
that many people who like hit like a
million followers or whatever who
aren't successful employees right now no
but like when I think of like OG when I
think of like the most successful
influencers from the franchise I think
of Becca and Amanda yeah Lauren Lauren
right but she's even though you don't
she's so disassociated on the franchise
associate her well that's true I
literally forgot JoJo yeah their wedding
looked really nice yeah it didn't and
like very pretty and I feel like the
franchise like did them dirty because
like we all thought like during the
season after that they were like shady
and and thirsty and fake and it turns
out they're like lovely people who are
so in love same with Ari and Lauren like
ever they made us hate Aryan Lauren so
much and they're just nice people yeah
no and they're very you know successful
influencers too as like a family there's
a lot of really successful
famous like Jaden Tanner Jayden Tannery
just doing their thing yeah crazy
um so the past five you definitely did
not need to know any of them no but now
you do and you didn't need to know that
Miles teller's grandma is a pea Joe yeah
that I didn't know and you kind of
needed to know that like Belle and Chris
Rock were an item because it's like what
and you needed to have the inside track
that Dominic West will be playing James
Brown right
so that's our show there'll be another
one tomorrow and there's a new episode
of the redheads if you're feeling RDH
that this episode is ending and Claudia
is on it so it's very the energy is
Toasty even though the redheads is
always toasty we always have a really
amazing time and the girls are so
wonderful and the books are sometimes
really great like this month yeah
thank you so much for listening to the
morning testimony Morning Show where we
deliver the fastest way you need to know
everybody the Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcasts anywhere podcast we found
some Spotify iTunes it's your public
radio I read you guys box all the places
we'll be listening about guys my name is
a better beautiful setting it's where we
are have an amazing amazing day and
we'll see you tomorrow for hump day bye